so late last week I had a few sort of
spare minutes in the craziness of
setting up the new studio and tweaking
things and I'll talk to you on the bonus
show about what's going on with all that
that I said let's see what's happening
on the news and I kind of flipped around
the cable news networks to see what was
going on I like to see what's happening
on Fox MSNBC and and CNN and I turned to
CNN and Jake Tapper was filling in for
Aaron Burnett's program and he was in
the middle of fact-checking Donald Trump
and I don't even remember what he was
fact-checking at the time it might have
been something related to the immigrant
Caravan or it might have been something
related to taxes I don't even really
remember at this point but it doesn't
matter because as I watched it it became
clearer than ever to me that
fact-checking
Donald Trump is effectively a pointless
waste of time and and what I mean is the
following when CNN fact checks Trump who
cares in the sense that you either
already know that Trump lies all the
time
and you care about that or you will call
CNN fake news because that has been the
sort of resounding repeated talking
point that we've seen from Trump and the
people around him about anybody who
tries to say that he is either saying
things that aren't true or attacking
people incorrectly or whatever else he
might be doing and even when you have
these other fact checkers or I guess we
could call them allied trackers correct
Trump but PolitiFact or the Washington
Post has like a lie tracker of some kind
Donald Trump has already preemptively
successfully primed the pump such that
people here fact-checking Oh Trump is
being fact-checked those are the lies
that's the fake news and this is in a
way brilliant this it's brilliant in how
effectively it has work and you've got
to really understand how bad this is a
focus on truth is no longer viable
as a strategy of enlightening people as
to what's going on politically and
moving the needle it doesn't matter so
if you said you know what I'm going to
try to step back from the left-right do
a sort of paradigm and instead of just
criticizing things from a left/right
perspective I'm going to focus just on
truth I'm going to try to figure out as
closely as it's possible to do this sort
of epistemological II what is true and
what is not true that narrative has been
co-opted and and maybe even better than
co-opted it has been debased and made
irrelevant where even just saying I
don't care about partisan bickering I
care about what we can demonstrate with
fact Trump has already primed the pump
so that his followers and too many of
those who say I'm not a trumpet but will
not care about that this is a massive
debasement of the discourse around
American politics but it's where we are
and we still want to win I think and
that's where the motivation for saying
this comes from that's where I am
motivated to say fact-checking Trump in
this way is a pointless waste of time
instead of fact-checking there's going
to need to be again if the if the focus
is winning and there's a place for a
focus on truth but if the focus is
winning there needs to be a complete and
total shift towards how is our platform
going to benefit people who work how is
it going to benefit people in the lower
middle class how is it not a threat from
the left that you will lose status
either real or perceived if Democrats
win because again I'm not saying I
believe that that's actually a risk but
the trumpets perceived that he would
protect them from a loss of the status
they either believe they have actually
have or hope to have in the future and
the trumpets have pulled off a brilliant
emotional scam because it's no longer a
sort of rational basis on which they
appeal to voters
it's an emotional basis that they
used to appeal to voters it is their
side that claims the facts don't care
about their feelings you know that
phrase that's become popular their
entire platform is based on feeling and
emotion it doesn't matter if the
Pentagon said as I will tell you later
on in the show that the immigrant
Caravan is not a threat to the national
security of the United States if they
feel like it is and if they can be sold
a bill of goods that claims that it is
then that's all that matters
it doesn't matter if tax cuts for the
rich just allow the rich to hoard money
without helping the economy which is the
reality if it feels like the fair thing
to do is to let rich people keep all
their money or more of their money
because after all it's their money and
they create jobs if that feels like a
good argument it's going to work it
doesn't matter if the facts don't bear
it out and look at how bad they are and
how much they lie is totally accurate I
talked to my talk about that on the show
and others talk about it but it's not
allowed Democrats to win in a country
that keeps moving to the left more and
more people believe for example that the
government has a basic right to provide
a basic duty to provide everybody with
some basic level of health care more and
more people than ever believe that and
yet our elected officials keep moving to
the right depending on how you measure
it this is absurd and it is very easy
for the left to take this approach of
hold on a second if we just talk sense
to people and tell them what the facts
are we will win well go look at the
youtube comments on my channel go look
at the tweets that I get travel to
Indiana as I recently did or go to
politican and talk to these people and
you will realize if we just say the
truth will win out we're fighting an
unwinnable battle and showing people the
facts explaining to them that their
priorities are misguided and part of
this decade-long right-wing scam to
trick them into supporting the same
status quo that got us into this mess
just doesn't work okay and a ton of
people I know people will write in and
say David a lot of these people are just
dumb well dumb is sort of starting to
get ad hominem e but there are people
who lack the cognitive capacity to
understand a lot of these issues but
many others are just living their lives
they're trying to earn a living they
don't have time to dig deeper than
whatever slanted headlines they're
getting or whatever catchphrase Trump is
using and Vox calls this an epistemic
crisis the idea is if one side rejects
the epistemic Authority of fact checking
and of knowable truth however you want
to say it the truth no longer matters
and it no longer speaks for itself
climate changes an example climate
science explains what's happening it's
overwhelming it's clear but so what it
hasn't changed the narrative among much
of the right at all and the more facts
they're presented with they either
ignore bury their head in the sand come
up with new anti scientific arguments
because once you question the authority
of the scientist which is what they've
done
once you question the value of the media
in general because you portray them as
the enemy of the people you are no
longer arguing on the merits of
arguments you're arguing in terms of
power fact-checking can work when you
have a society where authority and
trustworthiness and power depend on what
is demonstrable what you can prove and
what the facts are it doesn't right now
because we've fallen very very far so we
need something else I'm not sure what
but it has to start with voting tomorrow
because if Democrats recover some of the
Lost political capital tomorrow then
maybe we have something to talk about
if Democrats recover nothing in the
midterms I hate to tell you this but
it's going to be another two years of
exactly what we've had so people need to
vote today's program is sponsored in
part by deputies offering you ten
dollars just for trying their free
service at debet eyes dot-com / Pakman
this is a free app that can actually
help a lot of people get into better
situations with their personal finances
because what debet eyes does is it turns
any credit card into a debit card
meaning you can still earn your credit
card rewards and build credit and get
points or miles or whatever it is that
your credit card offers but you
eliminate the risk of going into debt
you can't afford or of accruing late
fees or paying interest because when you
sign up
linked your credit card to your checking
account you use your credit card like
you normally would and at the end of the
day debbye ties will withdraw however
much you charged on your card that day
from your checking account and set it
aside
without overdrafting your account at the
end of the month debe tais has already
paid your credit card bill for you on
time and automatically this is a really
good way for people who want an easier
way to pay bills on time and it's also
excellent for people who are trying to
stay on a budget and not go into debt by
spending more money than they have it's
also perfect if you're looking to have a
risk-free hassle free way of building
credit and earning rewards points and
once you set it up you don't have to go
in and mess with anything it's
completely automatic this is a really
important thing from what when I got my
first credit card with like a five
hundred dollar limit or something like
that at that point I decided I don't
charge anything I can't pay off at the
end of the month and I have thought of
my credit card as a debit card forever
and it's a really great practice for
people to get into you can enjoy debet
eyes totally free for as long as you
want by clicking the link under this
video and debba ties will give you ten
dollars just for trying it out